[Música]
boa noite a todos
hoje eu vim contar pra vocês uma
história de conexão primeiramente uma
conexão com o problema real
depois uma conexão com o propósito com
pessoas e por fim com uma missão e essa
trajetória e se o lá no final de 2015 eu
sou engenheiro ambiental e logo depois
da faculdade já ingressar no mestrado e
como você sabe é uma árdua jornada de
dois anos onde a gente desenvolve uma
pesquisa e já finalizando essa pesquisa
comecei a me questionar sobre o real
impacto que ela poderia causar na
sociedade que eu estava inserida e no
problema que eu estudava e a partir de
então começou um questionamento bom esse
ciclo do mestrado está se fechando e eu
vou iniciar outro e o que eu vou começar
a fazer daqui em diante
qual vai ser o próximo ciclo ea única
coisa que me vem à cabeça é empreender
empreender para resolver o problema que
eu estudava todos os dias desde a
graduação eu trabalhei com resíduos
sólidos que aquilo que a gente chama de
lixo sabe eo mestrado foi sobre a
filosofia lixo zero
então cada vez que estudava que me
aprofundava mais nesse conteúdo eu
tomava mais consciência de dados que me
aterrorizavam um quais são esses dados
de todo o lixo que você gera na casa de
vocês
tudo o que vai para a sacolinha de lixo
vai para o caminhão menos de 5% é
reciclado
todos os outros 95% acabou indo para
lixões ou para aterros sanitários como
esse e de tudo que está aqui de todo
esse volume que vocês estão vendo mais
da metade deles 52 por cento
correspondem à parcela orgânica são
restos de alimentos grama poda que
poderia virar adubo que é uma terra
preta rica em nutrientes 32 por cento
representam os materiais recicláveis
metal papel plástico vidro que poderia
ser reinserido na indústria através da
reciclagem como matéria prima mas ainda
disso tão aqui e apenas 16% de todo esse
volume que acabam
é um solitário deveria de fato estar
aqui por não ter qualquer valor de
reutilização reciclagem venda e os
outros 84 por cento estão sendo
completamente desperdiçados em um aterro
sanitário e como vocês podem imaginar
isso gera diversos impactos ambientais
desde o caminhão de coleta da sacolinha
até deixar aqui então o fluxo intenso de
caminhões nas estradas
o uso de combustível fóssil poluição
atmosférica
além disso poluição de água solo ea
desses locais e também uma problemática
social que envolve todas as pessoas que
vivem através do manuseio e manejo
desses materiais
mas além disso que a gente muito pouco
sabe é o grande e impactante problema
econômicos o que isso gera
no brasil todos os meses se gasta em
média 10 reais com 15 centavos por
habitante
todos os meses e se a gente imaginar que
isso é um mercado do lixo e isso
representa todos os anos a economia
brasileira 27 bilhões de reais e para
ter uma noção do quão grande é isso esse
é o terceiro maior orçamento da maioria
das prefeituras do brasil
ou seja se gasta com saúde educação
depois com gestão de resíduos e depois
com segurança cultura lá ver
então o governo gasta mais para levar
sua sacolinha de lixo para o aterro
sanitário do que para garantir a nossa
segurança
então talvez agora vocês compartilham um
pouco da minha tristeza e frustração
quando eu fiquei dois anos estudando
isso e tinha que colocar a minha
sacolinha de lixo na calçada para
acontecer a mágica do lixo onde passa o
caminhão recolhe o lixo para o mundo da
lei ele some e eu sabia que não era
assim
dessa forma eu me conectei com a
primeira conexão que foi com um problema
real é algo que afeta todos nós mesmos
que mesmo que a gente não tenha essa
consciência e ao longo dos anos onde
estudei resíduos sólidos eu sabia que
existe uma solução muito simples
pelo menos para parte desse resíduo que
corresponde os resíduos orgânicos
e que simplesmente não era aplicada
então imaginem se metade de todo esse
volume não precisasse sair da nossa
cidade
se esse adubo se esse resíduo orgânico
pudesse virar adubo através de um
processo chamado compostagem esse adubo
rico em nutrientes e volta para o solo
onde a gente vai executar agricultura e
criar nossos alimentos que vai pra
nossas mesas
e cada vez que a gente consome a gente
cozinha esses alimentos geram resíduos
orgânicos e esses resíduos orgânicos por
sua vez viram adubo que voltar pro solo
que vão gerar os alimentos que nem pra
nossa mesa completando dessa forma o
ciclo natural da natureza que a gente
rompe ao meio quando a gente encaminha
para um aterro sanitário
e foi aí que me conectei com o meu
segundo a ampla a minha segunda conexão
que é o propósito e eu me enxergar nesse
processo como uma possível agente de
mudança baseado nos meus conhecimentos
em tudo que eu já tinha trabalhado foi
fundamental
então eu me via como uma pessoa que
poderia buscar uma alternativa simples
para resolver isso
o problema é tão gigante e como fazer
isso né porque como é que transforma um
problema tão gigantesca uma solução
simples e com quem porque a gente sabe
que sozinho a gente não chega a lugar
nenhum então eu comecei a buscar
iniciativas no brasil que já estivessem
desenvolvendo algum tipo de solução para
isso e eu cheguei em duas iniciativas
uma é dentro de uma comunidade em
florianópolis há dez anos atrás eles
tiveram um surto de leptospirose porque
eles deixavam as sacolinhas na calçada e
o caminhão demorava para passar o início
de um cachorro rasgavam as sacolas e
atraía ratos que urinavam nas sacolas e
calçadas onde as pessoas tinham acesso o
que fez já um surto de leptospirose no
bairro a comunidade se juntou a pegar um
bônus iguais efe que vocês estão vendo
deixar em diversas casas e
estabelecimentos em mercadinhos do
bairro as pessoas não depositarem mas os
lixos no atacado na sacola e sim nessas
bombonas eles criaram uma associação que
pega esses resíduos para fazer
compostagem e hoje eles sobrevivem da
venda
os substratos biofertilizantes adubos
outra iniciativa que eu conheci
é no rio de janeiro e foi uma iniciativa
pioneira para pegar esse modelo de
negócio e trazer para a iniciativa
privada
mas mesmo assim seguindo atendendo aos
cidadãos pequenos geradores assim como
eu assim como vocês
a outra coisa que eu ouvi falar logo no
início da caminhada que foi fundamental
foi natália não tenha medo de contar
para os outros dos teus sonhos
nós brasileiros a gente tem muito forte
à nossa cultura que pode ter uma boa
idéia de quando a gente tem um sonho a
gente tem que guardar pra nós a gente
não pode compartilhar a ninguém porque
essa pessoa vai roubar o nosso sonho da
gente uma ideia é só uma idéia e tem que
investir muita energia para aquilo
acontecer então quando compartilha com
alguém essa pessoa está disposta a
investir essa energia é muito mais fácil
ela vive o teu parceiro ao invés de um
roubador de sonhos e outra coisa sempre
que tu conta com uma pessoa que eu sonho
que está automaticamente criando um
compromisso com ela se eu falar pra você
escutava tem de montar uma iniciativa
quando vocês me vissem de novo se eu
perguntar e natália como está a
iniciativa conseguiu tirar do papel e
foi eu comecei a fazer e eu comecei a
contar pra todo mundo meu sonho a contar
da solução que tinha pensado e disse eu
quero criar uma solução pra resolver o
problema de resíduos orgânicos na minha
cidade comecei a contar pra todo mundo e
dessa forma eu acabei chegando num rap
de negócio sustentáveis em porto alegre
onde reunia mais de 20 iniciativas todas
voltadas à sustentabilidade e eu fui num
evento em fevereiro do ano passado lá e
dentre várias palestras tinha essa
palestra acontecendo que era sobre uma
iniciativa agricultura urbana e ele
fechou a palestra dele dizendo que ele
considerava muito importante agregar à
agricultura o processo de compostagem
justamente para fechar esse ciclo que eu
acabei de falar e aquilo bateu em mim e
fechou exatamente com o que eu estava
pensando eu fui falar com os dois
rapazes dessa iniciativa no final da
palestra e as correntes dizer que hoje
eles são os fundadores da reciclo comigo
e menos de dois meses depois desse
evento a gente já estava com ela rodando
com essa iniciativa rodando
em porto alegre essa mesma forma a gente
conheceu a 12 andreza que são duas
pessoas e com que mantinha uma horta
comunitária em tramandaí no litoral do
rio grande do sul e pelo mesmo
compartilhamento de propósito a gente
acabou se alinhando e elas foram as
pessoas que levar a iniciativa para
outros dois municípios e vem então a
terceira conexão conexão com pessoas e
pessoas que compartilham o mesmo
propósito porque isto tá falando
abertamente do seu propósito é muito
comum que outras pessoas se juntem a ti
muito bem mas eu sigo aqui falando desse
modelo de negócio você ainda não sabe
que essa solução né
a gente entrega um baldinho para os
cidadãos que querem o serviço eles vão
colocando lá os resíduos orgânicos ao
longo da semana ea gente combina um dia
de coleta de bicicleta onde a gente
recolhe os resíduos orgânico leva para a
nossa área de compostagem
depois de quatro meses a gente gerou o
adubo que parte retorna para os clientes
como uma forma de mínimo que a gente
entrega todos os meses
o cliente escolhe um lado uma mudinha
pra gente aos poucos resgatando
agricultura urbana ea gente também
entregam um mimo surpresa pra favorecer
todos esses parceiros que a gente vai
encontrando ao longo dessa caminhada e
aí vem a quarta conexão que é a missão
qualquer missão dessa iniciativa porque
a gente acorda cedo todos os dias muitas
vezes não tem hora pra chegar em casa a
gente chega a 68 9 horas da noite
felizes e realizados porque tem um
porquê a gente quer desviar todo o
resíduo orgânico de aterros sanitários e
dessa forma transformar a um jeito como
as pessoas enxergam os resíduos
mostrando que sim existe um valor sim
existe um modelo muito mais eficaz para
lidar com isso do que encaminhar para
aterros sanitários e é isso que nos faz
acordar todos os dias e como resultado a
gente atua há dez meses a gente já
conseguiu coletar mais de 15 toneladas
de resíduos orgânicos de aterros
sanitários de bicicleta
a gente já a gente
tende continuamente mais de 150 famílias
em três municípios
a gente já atingiu diversas incontáveis
pessoas com palestras workshops e cursos
de capacitação e mais de 100 pessoas já
estão utilizando os minhocários na sua
casa para fazer por si só o processo de
compostagem e essa é a solução simples
então pra vocês assim o que eu
a imma a mensagem que eu gostaria de
deixar é primeiramente olhar ao redor
qual é o problema que a sociedade onde
vocês estão inseridas sofre um real
problema que as pessoas sofrem com isso
depois de que forma que consegue inserir
para solucionar essa problemática com os
seus conhecimentos quais são os seus
talentos para que se possa virar o
propósito de trazer realização pessoal
felicidade eu comprei isso quem são as
pessoas ao seu redor que podem
compartilhar esse sentimento desse
propósito contigo pois elas vão te
ajudar nessa trilha nessa caminhada
e por fim qual essa missão que vocês
querem atingir com tudo isso o que vai
fazer vocês acordarem cedo dormir tarde
e ainda por cima ficar feliz e eu gostei
de falar essa frase onde os meus
talentos e paixões encontro às
necessidades do mundo aí está o meu
caminho pois acho que ela resume todo
esses últimos minutos de fala muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]